and Gallagher on also known as and
Gallagher on the black is a minor
antagonist in JRR Tolkien's middle-earth
legendarium appearing in The
Silmarillion he was the most powerful
and infamous of all dragons bred by
Morgoth during the first age of
middle-earth
he is the largest dragon to have ever
lived and the greatest of all the winged
dragons the fire he Brill was hotter
than most other dragons but not hot
enough to destroy the One Ring or could
it more God breath and Callaghan
sometime in the late first Age and
Callaghan was intended to be an band's
last defense of an invasion he would
crush the enemy in obliterating Morgoth
made and Callaghan far more powerful
than even gloom his ancestor unlike
other dragons and Calvin could fly he
was the first of his kind to do so his
first appearance was when he burst out
of the volcano called Terran Gorham
during the war of Wrath and terrified
the hose of the Valar making them
retreat and consider ending the war
because of the immense casualties caused
by an Carrigan's devastating fire just
when it looked hopeless arendelle
Tourneur and the Eagles and his flock
arrived and they battled and Callaghan
and the other dragons soon almost all
dragons were defeated and arendelle for
and Calgon throughout the night as dawn
broke Thorin dark and Aaron who got the
upper hand and killed and Callaghan
hurling him out of the sky the Sun came
upon his death as an Callaghan smash and
tutoring ordinary mountains destroying
them and Carrigan's death ensure that
the host of the Valar would be
victorious the exact size and height of
Terran Gorham are unclear although they
were said to have been the tallest
mountains in middle-earth one drawing by
Tolkien illustrated in Karen Constance
the atlas of middle-earth if drawn to
scale would have made each more than
35,000 feet high and five miles across
so by any estimates as his fault
destroyed all three volcanic mountains
over eight kilometres in height his size
would have been anywhere between one to
five kilometers or 0.6 to three miles in
height as anything smaller than that
wooden
be able to destroy all three mountains
so going to the other corner Glover is
the given name of an underwater life
form that appears in Cloverfield and
Cloverfield paradox the creature was
created by Neville page and JJ Abrams
the monster came out from the Atlantic
Ocean where it was awakened by Tiger
watch a submarine sent down from the to
Ice Station to investigate the monster
rampages throughout manhattan destroying
the city in his bath this destruction
costs the United States government to
sacrifice New York City in an attempt to
kill the monster with heavy ordnance in
the hammer down protocol the monster is
a 240 to 300 foot high quadruped it with
a long try for pin tail the uppermost
double-jointed limp air is longer than
the other two ending in a multi fingered
hand which can bend backwards so that
the creature can walk on its fingers the
double-jointed squat legs are powerful
enough to support the creatures mass and
yet still allow it to move relatively
quickly for an organism of its size
clover as an adult is the eldest and
most powerful and biggest species in the
club of field monster franchise in the
first film the monster was a baby
this was hinted in the special features
of Cloverfield but this adult that
appeared in prom field paradox was way
bigger and yet again the actual height
of this is currently unknown but at the
end of the movie when it jumps out of
the clouds that are similar to
altocumulus clouds that have a minimum
height of 6,500 feet suggest that it had
a colossal height of almost two
kilometres or 1.2 miles this also
matches with the lowest altitude at
which the return cap suit could deploy a
parachute a rocket-powered landing
system which it had yet to do so when it
reached the clouds
however it should be noted that the
terrain and was standing on was not seen
and depending on the elevation of the
ground above sea level the specifics of
the clouds themselves the creatures true
height could still be a small fraction
of the above figure possibly even a mere
half kilometer or less so in total if we
account for the depth of the ocean wave
motion what
yes space capsules can only land in
oceans and seas as even with parachutes
and retrorockets the force of the impact
would destroy it anyway by any estimate
the clever monster could be anywhere
between two to five kilometers or one
point two to three miles depending on
the depth of the ocean the ocean could
be several hundred meters deep or
several kilometers deep so put in your
votes on which most is bigger as they
both have similar measurements also like
share and subscribe